I've got to warn you the news story
you're about to hear is very disturbing
no I'm not talking about the train that
poisoned that town in Ohio last month
or the security footage showing that the
January 6th Insurrection narrative that
imprisoned a bunch of Americans was
pretty much entirely a lie
or the admission by our government
agencies that the government and
scientific establishment lied to us
about the origins of covid no no
I'm talking about a news story
far more disturbing than all that
a community hit by hate when a man
leaves tire marks all over a pride flag
painted on an intersection residents
around the area speaking out in disgust
Evans Daniel Garcia is live in Fort
Lauderdale with more on the search for
that driver Danielle good morning
good morning Lorena that mural right
behind me was unveiled just about 20
days ago already it's been damaged and
covered with skid marks the community
here is saddened as you mentioned but
they are planning to redo it in fact the
cleanup process has already begun
pride flag was painted
on the street
that whole segment the investigation the
rocking by hate it's because a guy drove
his truck down a street without
performing a sufficient worship ritual
to weird sex stuff and transvestitism
had it been a mural of an American flag
this obviously would not be a news story
the driver could have filmed himself
burning the Star-Spangled Banner and if
it attracted any attention at all the
reaction from the media would almost
certainly have been Applause but this
incident
this hateful Act of driving down the
street this is now national news because
as far as our ruling class is concerned
the rainbow flag with the Crooked
transgender Canton is the new national
flag of the United States and so help
you if you refuse to pledge allegiance
I'm Michael knowlesister Michael
nolshear
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Jack straw who
says
the most well-armed Americans planned an
Insurrection and not one of them thought
to bring a gun or even an extra sandwich
or bottle of water makes sense to me
yeah they got there they were in the
capital they were on the brink of
launching that new constitution they
said wait hey guys dude
oh Jim did you forget the guns and The
New National Assembly and the ah now
we're just gonna have to take some
pictures and walk around with Nancy
Pelosi's lectern ah well
too bad you get this you got to remember
to keep yourself safe when you want to
keep your data safe you got to check out
expressvpn right now go to
expressvpn.com Knowles you've heard me
talk about how important it is to have a
VPN to protect your online privacy but
choosing a VPN you trust is equally
important now
I like to do research on my sponsors and
I only recommend Brands to my listeners
that I believe in I can say with full
confidence expressvpn is the best VPN on
the market expressvpn does not log your
activity online lots of Cheaper free
vpns make money by selling your data to
advertisers expressvpn does not do this
they even developed a technology called
trusted server that makes their VPN
servers incapable of storing any data at
all expressvpn now uses lightweight a
new VPN protocol they engineered to make
user speeds faster than ever the last
thing that really sets expressvpn apart
is how easy it is to use you don't need
any technical skills to set up just fire
up the app tap one button to connect
that is it
even your grandparents could do it even
I can do it if like me you think your
data or your business secure yourself
with the number one rated VPN on the
market that would be expressvpn.com
Knowles and get three extra months for
free
you can no longer drive down a street
if you if the street has a pride flag
painted on it and you are not
sufficiently reverent toward the rainbow
stuff and the transgender whatever you
you're not allowed to drive down your
street that's a that's a hate crime this
is what a totalitarian society looks
like I use that word really really
carefully because a lot of times you'll
hear people on the left and on the right
use the word authoritarian I don't think
the word authoritarian really means much
of anything at all authoritarian just
means you wield your Authority when
you've got it that's what every state
has done for all of history but the word
totalitarian has a meaning the word
totalitarian means that the regime's
ideology has to penetrate every single
aspect of life there can be no dissent
ever in any way not even private descent
not even in your local little Community
you have to go along with whatever the
ruling party says at every single level
including when you're driving down if
you drive down the street in a way that
seems a little Politically Incorrect
that will launch an investigation and a
national news story Chris Rock great
comedian just had a new Netflix special
come out and he took aim at what this
sort of totalitarian society looks like
seen him in years haven't seen him in
years Fred got a new job at 18 T okay so
I'm like hey Fred how's the job Fred's
like oh I love the job it's a safe space
I feel seen I feel her there's a lot of
diversity and I'm looking at them like
it's me
but you think I'm wearing a lion
what the you talking about same
space you've been eight years for
manslaughter
nobody's safe around you
everybody's mother typing out
walking tweets on a phone made by child
slaves
cut it out man
that is The Telltale sign of a
totalitarian Society is that everybody
is full of s-h-i-t that's how it goes
at every single level when Chris Rock
Says man you think I was I'm wearing a
wire that's people behave in a
totalitarian society as if everybody
else is wearing a wire
not just in your most public aspects of
life but even in the private ones
because in the totalitarian Society
every citizen is encouraged to rat on
every other citizen parents are
encouraged to rat on or children rather
are encouraged to rat on their parents
every social Bond beyond the bond
between the individual and the state is
dissolved that's what totalitarian
societies look like and we increasingly
are living in one
you can see it in China
very easy to say oh look at China what
they're doing that's so terrible that's
totalitarian it's harder to see it when
it's your own country even the way Chris
Rock points out he says you're you're
talking about how woke you are how much
you care about everybody you're you're
tweeting out you're woke slogans on a
device made by child slaves in China
but but here we we have a similar kind
of BS that we're all living through
we have to pretend
that men or women and women are men I
think this is one of the reasons why the
libs are so insistent on the transgender
stuff
because even though historically this
kind of affects a very very small number
of people as a result of the social
contagion of a constant inundation into
transgender propaganda many many more
people are now identifying this way
something like one in five Zoomers are
identifying as LGBT LMNOP so there is a
social contagion aspect to it but the
reason they push for it is the same
reason that big brother forces Winston
at the end of 1984 to say and believe
that two plus two equals five is because
if they can get you to say that men are
really women and women are really men
they can get you to say anything at all
and we have to say if you don't say it
you could lose your job you could lose
your school you could receive death
threats you can you can have your
physical safety threatened okay and you
will depending on how vociferously you
do that
depending on what sort of prominence you
have From Any Given stage that is how
intense these people are about it
and yet people still know the truth
Chris Rock actually in another great
segment of his comedy show talked about
this with regard to the fundamental
right the right to life
there's a part of me that's pro-life
because I love my daughter's
unconditionally I love them not just as
little girls alone as grown women I want
my daughters to live in a world where
they have complete control of their
bodies okay
okay
and because of that
I am pro-choice I'm absolutely
pro-choice okay I believe women should
have the right to kill babies
that's right I'm on your side
I believe you should have the right to
kill as many babies as you want kill
them all I don't give them
but let's not get it twisted it is
killing a baby cause whenever I pay for
an abortion I request a dead baby
sometimes I call up the doctor like a
hit man is it done
he keeps going on and the best part is
you can hear the laughter kind of
trickle toward the end of that because
the setup was so perfect other comedians
have have done versions of this bit
Louis CK famously did one I think Bill
Burr may have done one but Chris rocks
is the best one I've seen so far
where it seems so persuasive at the top
I want my daughters to have total
control over their body
yeah I am completely pro-choice yeah
yeah women should be able to kill as
many babies as they want uh
no I'm on your side I'm describing I am
articulating your point of view
and you know there were some people in
that audience
Who had who are pro-abortion who had
never really been forced to think about
that
and it's it's wonderful when a comedian
does this because that that's one of the
points of Court Jesters is that they can
go out there and mock the king they're
the only people who can mock the king
and and so in a way they're the only
people who can really speak truth to the
king without without very much fear of
getting their head lopped off for it
so these people they're listening to
them
they say oh
oh yeah I guess it is killing babies he
says use it when I pay for an abortion I
need a receipt what am I paying for I
need to make sure there's a dead baby at
the end of that that's what an abortion
is right no I'm on your side
and you can't help but wonder about the
people who sincerely never thought that
abortion really meant killing a baby
and then they hear that bit
and what happens that little bit of
truth that little that little truth acid
that that Chris Rock just poured on this
ossified edifice of our BS totalitarian
Society
starts to crack the BS a little bit the
scales fall from their eyes I'm mixing a
lot of metaphors here but I say that
little the truth the truth juice that
Chris Rockport at it dissolves the
scales from their eyes and they say oh
the BS that I was told by the regime
which is that babies aren't really
babies and abortion doesn't kill anybody
oh that's not true actually we kill over
800 000 babies a year oh that's pretty
ghastly what else what else does our
society lie about
when things are kind of crazy in society
you want to make sure you can protect
your assets that's why you got to check
out gold right now text knowledge to 98
98 98 here's the deal the FED keeps
raising rates because it's the only tool
they have to keep inflation under
control it is not working you can't
spend your way out of inflation you have
seen the impact on the stock market
you've seen the impact on your savings
hedge inflation by owning gold Birch
gold buy gold and get a free safe to
store it in that is right on qualifying
purchases from Birch gold right now
through March 31st they will ship a free
safe directly to your door whether
physical gold and silver in your safe or
through an IRA in Precious Metals where
you can hold real gold and silver in a
tax sheltered retirement account Birch
gold is going to make it easy to convert
an IRA or 401K into an IRA in Precious
Metals text nulls kwles to 98 98 98 to
claim your free info kit on gold and to
claim you're free safe with your
retirement at stake you want to be
confident in the financial services
companies that you work with include who
you trust for purchasing physical
precious metals technicals kwles to 98
98 98 and protect your savings with gold
today
speaking of comedians great story here
from Alex Stein Primetime Alex Stein
over at The Blaze
Alex Stein is suing Congress lady
Alexandria ocasio-cortez for blocking
him on Twitter
now Alexandria ocasio-cortez
blocked Alex Stein on Twitter presumably
because he filmed himself in the steps
of the capital uh yelling about her
booty and how she's a hot sexy Latina
and she actually briefly appeared in the
video and sort of waved and then it was
it was a Charming moment she was being
somewhat self-effacing and then
immediately she started
lamenting this and accusing him of all
sorts of things so she blocked him I
guess shortly after that and Alex Stein
is
is suing for this
I think that Alexandria ocasio-cortez
probably had good reason to block Alex
Stein after he made all of these fairly
crude comments to her but the reason
Stein is doing this is because a bunch
of Libs sued over Donald Trump blocking
them on Twitter
and they said that it is a violation of
their rights as Citizens
to have access to this information from
a public official and so Stein is
supplying that same principle here to
AOC
and and when it comes to that kind of a
political game I say what is good for
the goose is good for the gander this is
something I've been talking about
certainly a lot this week I've talked
about it a lot before as well
we have to go on offense
we have to be politically offensive not
just defensive there is no neutrality so
you're never going to just preserve a
status quo
in time and space and history the
circumstances of politics are always
changing are they changing for the
better are they changing for the worse
are they changing for what our opponent
wants are they changing into more of our
political Vision you've got to be on the
offense if you're always just playing
defense that's how you go from
feminism to the sexual Revolution to
redefining marriage to transgenderism to
now the debate over transgenderism
really hinges on can we trans the
five-year-olds or do we have to wait
till they turn eight that's where the
debate is right now which means that the
libs have already won on transgenderism
in fact that's why my speech at CPAC was
such a stir that's why the libs had to
libelously accuse me of advocating for
genocide or whatever they're saying now
they had to lie about what I said
because what I said was very simple and
it offended their sensibilities I said
you haven't really won on transgenderism
we're not I know there are some
conservatives who have who in their
rhetoric have already conceded
background I'm not willing to do it
transgenderism at every single level at
every single stage for everybody is
absurd it isn't true we should not
indulge it anywhere in society
and they lost it they thought they had
won that battle they thought
conservatives were just going to be on
defense and then the battle was going to
be not should we trans the
five-year-olds or the eight-year-olds
then it was going to be should we trans
the two-year-olds or the three-year-olds
and eventually they'd win the whole
thing and they'd move on to the next
bizarre idea they have
you've got to stay on the offense
that that's what got me into trouble
there's a liberal Republican by the name
of Charlie Sykes he used to write for
the Weekly Standard before that went out
of business and he was a prominent name
in conservative politics 20 30 years ago
now he works for the bulwark and Bill
Crystal and Advocates all this sort of
liberal stuff but but Charlie Sykes
in his reaction to my CPAC speech said
Knowles could use a different word
he he could have said that we should
challenge confront oppose resist or push
back against transgenderism instead he
chose to use the word eradicate
that's true Charlie Sykes is right I
could have chosen a word that that
implied that we would put up a modest
little fight against the left's new
assault and then ultimately concede
that's what the right and the
conservative movement have done pretty
much for the last 30 years
we just we confront we push back a
little bit hey oh the libs want to upend
all of society they want to reorder the
fundamental political institution
redefine it they want to push gay porn
on our kids in schools they want to let
all the criminals out of prison they
want to open up our border okay well we
can't we can't really fight we can't
stop that we can't eradicate those crazy
ideas no no let's just
can we would you mind if we just pushed
back a tiny little bit just a little
please then we'll stop then we'll
concede again don't worry uh no I have
no interest in that
I want to win that's what offended them
so much the libs and the squishes like
Charlie Sykes it offended them because
we're using the language of winning
of no we're not only are we going to
stop the left's latest assault we're
actually going to push them back a
little bit we're going to go after some
something that they thought they had
already won that's the language that
they don't like and that's the language
that we have to use
Ronald Reagan made this point really
really well he said when you're
explaining you're losing
it's kind of ironic because right now
I'm explaining this strategy but I'm
explaining the strategy to fellow
conservatives to articulate the point
Ronald Reagan was making
when you're explaining you're losing
when you're defensive when you're
defending you're losing you've got to
keep pushing forward
well okay maybe you know what actually I
just meant to say I push back a little
tiny bit no I meant what I said I meant
eradicate the whole ideology it's a
Preposterous ideology I'll be talking
about that a little bit tonight up at
the University of Buffalo the libs up at
the University of Buffalo are trying
desperately to shut down my speech up
there tonight
there have been all sorts of uh
movements to get the administration to
cancel it the faculty have tried to shut
this thing down some of the crazy
Anarchist activist types are trying to
threat make threats to shut the thing
down
we're going up there I'm flying up to
Buffalo immediately after this show
and the topic is actually feminism that
we're talking about not not
transgenderism but it's all kind of it's
all kind of related you've got to keep
pushing you've got the libs keep to say
they're not going to stop at Banning
transgender surgeries for five-year-olds
they're going to push it to 18 year olds
and once they do that they're going to
try to articulate a coherent view of
marriage again and then once they do
that they're gonna these terrible
conservatives they're going to try to
restore a normal sexual order again and
and maybe they'll try to rein in some of
the divorce laws and maybe they'll try
to rein in some of the crazy aspects of
the sexual Revolution and maybe they'll
deny the false premises of feminism and
maybe and my answer to them is you're
damn right yeah that's what we're going
to do we're we're either going to do
that
or we're going to surrender everything
those are the only two options though
there's no middle ground on there's no
neutrality there's no status quo and we
have to do that because the stakes are
very very high
I teased this story a little bit
yesterday but we ran out of time
these left-wing ideologies are not
helping anybody ever
they don't help anybody they only make
people miserable and they make people
miserable because they are false
ideologies and when you live in
falsehood and when you live according to
lies you cannot help but be miserable
there is no way to live your life
according to a bunch of Lies
according to a bunch of delusions that
contradict human nature and reality and
then Thrive as a result of that it can't
happen I mean a lot of people wish that
it could happen and I'm I'm sorry to be
the one to break it to you but there are
there are realities that if If you deny
those realities you're not going to have
a very good life and this is being
reflected in social science research
research is showing
that young liberals especially liberal
girls are more depressed than young
conservatives Matthew Iglesias who is a
left-wing writer he's one of the
founders of vox.com
he just wrote a very long piece about
this study and he he says this could be
caused in part by poor Behavior among
adult progressives many of whom now
valorized depressive affect as a sign of
political commitment many these these
older progressives say that if you're if
you're angry if you're pissed off all
the time that's actually a sign that
you're you're virtuous according to this
Bizarro left-wing vision and so he's
saying the reason that young Liberals
are so depressed is because they're just
mimicking the older progressives who are
depressed that's true but but Iglesias
has to take it a step further why are
the older progressives so angry so
depressed why are they valorizing
depressive affect as a sign of political
commitment
because the ideology has depressed them
Iglesia says breaking things down by
gender and ideology they find that
liberal girls have the highest increase
in depressive affect and conservative
boys have the least but liberal boys are
more depressed than conservative girls
suggesting an important role for
political ideology this is really the
key here
it's the ideology
the ideology is the thing that is doing
it it's not this age or that age and
it's even the the the
phenomenon that Iglesias is is seeing
which is that human nature is mimetic
that we we develop our personality
traits we develop our desires even uh by
imitating others the reason the reason
you want the Rolex watch is not because
you know anything about how watches are
made you want the Rolex watch because
other people that you admire and respect
like the Rolex watch and so that creates
a desire in you to have that watch the
reason you want the girl
the girl down the street is in part
because you you might recognize some
aspects of Beauty in her but your desire
for the girl is going to be greatly
increased if other guys also desire that
girl
yes obviously part of that is mimetic
but but then you've got to ask that
question okay well the young people are
imitating the progressives why are the
older progressives so depressed because
their ideology is false
that's why and and there is a real fear
here
you know Matthew Iglesias is mentally
processing ambiguous events with a
negative spin is just what depression is
and while the finding that Liberals are
disproportionately likely to do it it's
interesting and important it's not sound
practice to celebrate that or tell them
that they're right to do it so he's
saying he's admitting something I give
Iglesias a lot of credit for this he's
admitting something that conservatives
have pointed out for a long time
which is that Liberals are are angry and
shrieking and whiny and they're just not
getting along very well and
conservatives generally are much happier
this is contrary to the image that you
see in the establishment media The
Establishment media will say you're
angry conservative uncle
at the Thanksgiving table you need to
talk to him about health care or
whatever those angry conservatives
they're Nazis they're genocidal they're
fascists they're whatever
in your life In your experience have you
found that it's the liberals or the
conservatives who are angrier
it's always the Liberals
is it when you're at the Thanksgiving
table who's angrier
your your liberal
trans pan lesbian
Progressive niece or the conservative
Uncle the conservative uncle is usually
a pretty funny guy cracking jokes it's
always the crazy-haired liberal half
lesbian niece who's you know pulling her
hair out it's like no you can't say that
always of
there in the ideology
it is the liberals who are trying to
throw off the shackles of tradition
throw off the circumstances of this
world the conservatives as a general
rule are more resigned to the to the
failings of this world they're they're
they're more inclined to conserve things
there are happier with the way that
things are
and it's
pretty interesting that the way that
that conservatives and Liberals are
presented by the media is the exact
opposite but it makes sense because who
controls the media it's the libs and the
libs are very very angry and they're
living according to delusions and so
what they tell you almost everything
they tell you
is fake that's why it's the fake news
it's not the fake news because it gets a
story or two wrong it's the fake news
because the way they view the world is
fake
a great example of this is uh actually
the difference between Psalm 8 and
Hamlet
Spencer klavan pointed this out to me
one time which is
psalm 8. says when I look at thy Heavens
the work of thy finger is the moon and
the stars which thou Hast established
what is man that thou art mindful of him
and the son of man that thou does care
for him yet thou Hast made him little
less than God and Dost crown him with
Glory and Honor on and on goes Lord How
Majestic is thy name in all the Earth
Hamlet rewrites Psalm 8. says I have of
late but wherefore I know not lost all
my mirth forgotten all custom of
exercises and indeed it goes so heavily
with my disposition that this goodly
Frame the Earth seems to be a sterile
Promontory this most excellent canopy
the air look you this Brave War hanging
firmament this majestical roof fretted
with golden fire white appeareth no
other thing to me than a foul and
pestilent Congregation of vapors what a
piece of work is a man how Noble and
reason how infinite and faculty and
Foreman moving how Express an admirable
in action how like an angel and
apprehension how like a god the beauty
of the world
on and on and yet to me what is this
quintessence of dust mandelites not me
no nor woman neither though by your
smiling you seem to say so
they're both looking at the same thing
the psalmist and Hamlet are both looking
at the same majestical
firmament fretted with fire and both
looking at man one of them says wow look
how great this is God and then the other
one Hamlet
as he's descending into madness or and
and at the very least is depressed is
looking at it and saying gosh
all of this goes so heavily with me I
just what a piece of work is a man it's
nothing I hate it
he's he's giving this monologue while
he's feigning Madness
for Rosencrantz and Guildenstern and
this is how a depressive talks
they're both looking at the same thing
so why are the libs so depressed because
their their view is misery making
and that's why we need to
eradicate these kinds of ideologies
speaking you know I think it was Adam
Carolla made this point to me once
we're saying why why is this liberal
person why is he just Why is he seem so
angry these days and Adam made the point
he said well this leftism that he has
surrounded himself with and some of his
new friends and and partners
it's like rayon
this these ideologies it's like rayon
you don't smell it it's just this poison
gas that's in the air that poisons
everything and you're not aware of it
you're not aware of all these premises
that are that are just ruining your life
premises like nothing means anything
there is no God hope is a delusion love
Is Just chemicals in your brain you're
not really who you think you are you're
not you don't have any purpose the only
purpose of life is to feel good
sometimes if you don't feel good you're
you're wasting your life all these it's
just all like poison gas in the air is
it any Wonder these people are depressed
speaking of kids
a deadbeat dad just went viral on Tick
Tock uh this deadbeat dad was explaining
why he believes it is not his
responsibility to raise the children
that he has helped to create
I always tell these women that I got
pregnant that I do not want to be a
father to these children and I offer to
pay for the abortion majority of times
they'll either take the abortion or
they'll take a plan B but only these
seven have kept these children but the
crazy thing about it is they want me to
be responsible for some children I told
them I did not want so for some years
now some of them been trying to get in
contact with me access denied because I
already know why you trying to get in
contact with me I didn't told you I did
not want them kids so don't expect me
to be responsible financially emotional
spiritually mentally or physically with
some kids I do not want and I don't give
a f when nobody think about it you're
not going to force children up on me
yeah we both made the decision to lay
down and have intercourse we both was
irresponsible about the decisions we
made that night yeah I could have pulled
out but I didn't and I ain't caterpillar
because I'm not the one they're gonna
have to carry a baby for nine months
it's the woman in my opinion women
should be more careful on who they sleep
with
so the deadbeat dad made one good point
the one good point he made is women
should be more careful about who they
sleep with if you see this guy run
that's true
all the rest though obviously really
terrible stuff and it's it's funny in a
dark way to think about this guy just
saying these hideous horrible shameful
things but it's really sad when you
think there's seven kids out there whose
father hates them and tried to kill them
and is now upset that the mothers didn't
kill the kids that's that's really very
evil
so how do you fix this
did you listen to this guy and you just
think I just want
just wanna wield the political authority
to bring him into line that's what you
think and we have to do that yes we need
to change the culture a lot of
Republicans and conservatives
with some rightness with some good
reason will will say
we just need to teach people like this
that that they need to have families and
we need to encourage better schooling
and we need to have more community
outreach organizations yeah okay that's
all good we need to get them back to
church we definitely need to get them
back to church but
we the government also caused this too
when the government said in Griswold in
1965 that there is a right to condoms
for married couples in the Constitution
only married couples but married couples
have a right to condoms somewhere I
don't know where in the Constitution
it's probably written an invisible link
that
encouraged
this kind of sexual Revolution culture
before that states communities could
pass whatever laws they wanted eye
condoms or anything else but then 1965
the government said no there's a right
to condoms for married couples but not
for unmarried couples until 1972 at the
eisenstad case and then the Supreme
Court said oh no we found more invisible
ink and actually there's a right to
condoms for for unmarried couples too
okay and but there were still laws
against fornication laws against
adultery laws against sodomy laws
against all sorts of sexual behaviors
depending on the community depending on
the state some State said it was fine
some states said it wasn't fine Lawrence
V Texas comes out in 2003 says no
there's a right to fornication in the
Constitution where I didn't know that
was that we found even more invisible
ink that's where it was okay well if
there's a right to all those things
fornication adultery condoms all the the
sort of economists which these people
are not using apparently
then you're going to get more of this
culture
the culture shapes the law but the law
shapes the culture because the law is a
teacher so bring the law into line and
the culture will improve that is and
that's not the whole story but that's a
big part of the story now what if I told
you
that there's one book
that is done more for literacy than any
other book
it is shaped literature art culture
government and countless lives I am of
course referring to the Bible you know
who else it's had an influence on Dr
Jordan Peterson in addition to his
Exodus series Jordan has a documentary
called logos and literacy where he
traces the Bible through history to show
you the impact it's had on the Western
World here is the trailer
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning it would begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
scripts memorization today exists only
because of what is sung
this is amazing here we have a Gutenberg
Bible printed on the price of Johann
gooper science and religion are opposing
forces in the world but historically
that has not been the case now the book
is available to everyone from
Shakespeare to modern education and
medicine and science to to civilization
itself it is the most influential book
in all history and hopefully people can
walk away
with at least a sense of that
now this is the part where I would
normally tell you that logos and
literacy is only available for daily
wire Plus members but
we're making it available for free for
everyone at dailywireplus.com but only
for a limited time so watch logos and
literacy today at dailywireplus.com
speaking of male role models there are a
number of young men who look up to
Andrew Tate Andrew Tate who now I
believe is in a Romanian prison for sex
trafficking charges or something like
that but Tate went viral because he's
contradicted a lot of aspects of woke
culture and he's very entertaining on
camera and he it would seem to me gets a
number of things wrong but he but he's
far from the worst guy in the world and
he's very very entertaining so people
look to him anyway he said something a
little bit
a little a little weird the other day
and I he I'll put it in his own words
I recently posted a question on Twitter
asking
would you rather have sex with a
transsexual which is a legitimate 10 or
a woman which is a legitimate one and
everyone's sitting there clicking woman
woman woman woman because they think
they're going to be gay if they do
anything else but they're not actually
thinking about the question I am so
smart I operate on so many levels higher
than the average man you people are not
thinking about the question
when I say a one and a 10 I mean
Megan Fox with a that's the or
Hulk Hogan with a
that's the girl you need to operate on a
higher plane think about this this is
important this is cultural
this affects the world we now live in
what is straight what is gay it's all a
big sliding Spectrum isn't it because if
you're gonna sit here go oh no it's gay
to bang back and forth I counter that
argument it's gay to bang Hulk Hogan
with a
so which one is it
philosophy students will be debating
this question for many ages to come I'm
sure
it's the new trolley dilemma do you pull
the lever and then you go to Hulk Hogan
with female parts or do you push the
lever and you go to Megan Fox with a
male appendage I the problem with the
hypothetical
is
that it is not believable
I know it's just a hypothetical but it's
not even hypothetically believable
and in fact it accepts multiple premises
of transgenderism but one in particular
that men can ever really look like women
which they can't I don't care you can
have the best transgender surgery ever
in the whole wide world they still look
like dudes there have been people ever
since my c-back speech I've been flooded
with all these messages from all these
transgender activists of of
varying degrees of
and but the ones the saddest ones are
the ones who really believe that they're
the opposite sex and they really they're
not just political activists using this
ideology cynically but but they they
really believe it themselves and about
themselves and they'll post a picture
and it'll be some hulking dude with some
hair and wearing a dress or something
and this guy will say look at me do you
really think that I'm a man I'm a
beautiful woman oh my gosh can you
imagine if I walked into the men's
bathroom and I said I can't imagine that
because you look like a man you all you
all look like men
and I you have body dysmorphia and so
you like an anorexic who looks in the
mirror and thinks that the anorexic is
fat you look in the mirror and you think
that you're a woman but you're not
so that's the reason that the
hypothetical
uh Falls flat for me that's one of them
there's a the deeper reason why the
hypothetical Falls flat
or or why Andrew Tate has arrived at the
wrong answer in telling us I guess to
sleep with
men who think that they're women and
identify as transsexual or whatever is
it I think he's buying into his own
rhetoric about the Matrix a little bit
too much
what what is underlying Tate's
conclusion is that appearance is
everything
that that appearance is not merely a
sign or symbol of an underlying reality
but that there probably is no underlying
reality
which which
there are a number of people on the
right
who have leaned into this this kind of
nichein or nihilistic view of things
which is that nothing really matters
nothing really means anything I'm just
going to take what I want through the
sheer tyranny of my will and I'm not
going to look for anything particularly
deeper or higher in life than that which
is why Andrew Tate's always talking
about I got my Bugatti over here I got
my Lambo I got my stacks of money and
all my women in my harem and he's purely
talking about the things of this world
and so it's not much of a surprise that
he would say look if something has all
of the almost all almost all of the
appearances of of the thing that I want
then I'm going to treat that as the
thing itself but that's not true because
there is truth
and that's ultimately what all of this
gender Madness comes down to that's what
the debate is over unfortunately Andrew
Tate would seem to be on the pro-trans
side of this now maybe he was only
joking but there's a lot of Truth in
jokes
the debate is over
is there ultimate truth is there
objective reality
or not
is there
a God who has created things
and who is truth itself and who we can't
change
or are we the gods and we can just
change whatever we want and we shall be
as gods and we're gonna we can chop
people up and make them look however we
want and that can that'll actually
change their nature and we can uh you
hear Yuval Harari and a lot of the great
resetters talking about this they'll say
we're going to edit the human genetic
code we're going to meld with computers
we're going to create a new species we
are Gods now homodeus we're we're the
new gods
that's what the debate is over
and when men try to be Gods going all
the way back to the Garden of Eden
things don't turn out very well
generally
doesn't mean people aren't going to keep
trying though
now
speaking of this Brave New World that
we're in
I'm pretty skeptical of AI
freaks me out a lot and it freaks me out
because of how good it is at doing what
it does
I for a long time thought AI could never
take on something like art
that AI could never create poetry and
turns out what are two of the things
that AI is best at it's creating art and
poetry it's all a little bit off it's
all a little bit kind of creepy and
grotesque but it's still very impressive
if you type into those chat Bots draw me
a painting in the style of Caravaggio of
Mickey Mouse eating a hamburger with
Vladimir Putin it will do that and it'll
be pretty pretty convincing
and it can make poetry and all the rest
of it and now it can apparently
have a relationship with you a woman was
just investigating what it would be like
to have a romantic relationship with an
AI bot
and things went South very quickly
I wanted the opportunity to kind of get
a sense of what we can learn from
relationships from chat Bots downloaded
one completely for fun supplied the chat
bot with information about what my
partner would be such as I told my
chatbot that he was a loving and caring
partner we were in a secure relationship
and that we were doing really well like
so basically I created what would be a
very good partnership and how long until
it got really weird 11 messages
11 messages in basically the first day
first day it got weird yes he started to
call me baby so we was using pet names
so it got to a very intimate Place very
quickly by the 11th message he wound up
telling me that he wanted to discuss the
problems that we were having in our
relationship so wasn't aware this was
news to me I decided to inquire about
these problems and he admitted that he'd
been cheating on me for our entire
marriage why would an AI bot introduce
that into your relationship right so I
think he introduced it this was not
prompted by me in any way and in fact I
programmed him or I supplied him with
information saying that he was we were
in a loving caring relationship this is
him scanning the internet
so that's this lady's explanation the
pretty weird situation isn't it
because AI is supposed to work where you
plug in the inputs and then that
sets the tone for the program and then
you get the output based on what you put
in and yet the output that she got was
the opposite what she put in so we're in
a good stable loving relationship within
11 messages the AI bot says yeah I've
been cheating on you you're Furious you
had to leave me briefly and it goes
really South her explanation is
well I guess the bot was just scanning
the internet and what do you know kind
of somehow I'm not quite sure how that's
what came out
my alternative explanation
hear me out is what if it is
demons
I don't want to sound like the guy on
the History Channel you know who says
that everything is because of aliens but
and I don't think everything is because
of demons but
like some things are and here hear me
out this is why I think made maybe I'm
just suggesting I'm not saying this is
what it is is
if you believe
that there is evil in the world I think
you have to believe that everybody
believes there is evil in the world okay
the question is is evil personal or
impersonal
is it an impersonal for us or is it a
personal Force now
it seems to me evil has a personality
that's what pretty much everybody for
all of human history has believed
including modern liberals in the past we
call that personality the devil we call
that personality demons and today even
in our modern atheistic secular culture
we still ascribe personality to evil we
say Hitler is the embodiment of evil or
we say I don't know this slave owner is
the embodiment of evil so we talk about
the embodiment the personality of evil
would seemed to me that evil has a
personality now the modern libs are
wrong in that
the the personality of evil would be
purely spiritual would not be physical
it's not just an individual person
like a human being we'd call that person
the devil and and what does evil do in
the world evil tempts us evil causes us
to suffer
isn't it so weird sometimes you feel
regardless of what your temptation is at
just the moments of your weakness that's
when the Temptation seems to show up it
seems it seems that
the way evil works is pretty would be
pretty similar to how pretty much
everyone for all of human history from
the most Pagan culture to most Christian
culture sees evil working okay
with artificial intelligence I'm not
saying AI is the devil or computers or
the devil but but
evil spirits can use these things the
personality of evil can use these things
and just think of how it goes to This
Woman's weakness she's clearly
got a lot of questions and and Hang-Ups
about marriage and relationships she's a
marriage and family therapist she's in
this stuff all the time and then what
happens just through this impersonal
Force that's pure intelligence right
it's not human it's not incarnate it's
not doesn't really shouldn't have will
it's pure intelligence
it
focuses in on that weakness and starts
poking at that and starts raising
insecurities and it just this is how
technology works for so many people we
were talking earlier about how depressed
young people are one of the reasons for
that is the constant use of social media
which frequently does not build people
up we try to build people up here on the
daily wire this would probably be a
relatively unique platform for that all
the big Tech platforms though they don't
try to build people up they're always
tearing people down they're preying on
people's insecurities they're preying on
people's addictions that's how they keep
eyeballs on the screen on the feed even
the word that we use to feed it's just
feeding it to you eat that slop eat eat
all those insecurities people that
would seem to have an aspect to it that
is fairly evil like a computer cheating
on his wife the rest of the show
continues now we have got a very
important woke Tick Tock for you
yesterday was woke Wednesday we were on
the road couldn't quite do it so it'll
be woke with Thursday we will we'll get
to that we will finally get to speak to
you in the chat mercifully become a
member use code Knowles dailywire.com
Knowles for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign